premier entretien reggane coeur bat sauf
le climat semble beau mais la presse
s'est tenue à l'écart
une éclaircie pour le chômage en france
légère baisse en octobre comme le mois
précédent
nouvelle démarche française et
britannique en faveur des otages retenus
au liban de football début des matches
retour du championnat de france le paris
saint germain toujours invaincus
mesdames messieurs bonsoir ils ont
beaucoup à se dire mais rien à déclaré
aux journalistes c'est ce qu'on retient
d'abord ce soir de la première rencontre
entre ronald reagan et mikhaïl
gorbatchev à genève l'ambiance des
entretiens semble excellente en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on dit des deux côtés et on
a constaté que les conversations ont
duré plus longtemps que prévu
mais sur le fond c'est un peu le mystère
puisque soviétiques et américains ont
annoncé dès ce matin et d'un commun
accord un black out total à l'égard de
la presse sur place
à genève mais mona à fidji hintermann
nous résume la première journée de ce
sommet historique le président américain
attendait depuis un bon quart d'heure
soufflant sur ses mains le temps et
glacial
ici aussi à genève et puis à 10h05
l'image qui fera le tour du monde plus
qu'une rencontre entre deux hommes
le face à face de deux empires pour la
première fois depuis six ans pour faire
connaissance
messieurs reagan et leur bac choc de
laisse parler en tête à tête pendant 15
minutes
ils resteront seuls avec les interprètes
pendant plus d'une heure
cette durée est un bon signe consentir à
dire monsieur gorbatchev
avant de nous prévenir ne vous
précipitez pas pour écrire n'importe
quoi avant de savoir ce qui ce passe
cette mise en garde n'a pas suffi pour
nous empêcher d'être surpris tout à fait
à la mi journée à derry terre puis
soviétique sont venus nous avertir que
le président reagan et monsieur mikhaïl
gorbatchev avait décidé d'imposer un
black out total sur l'ensemble des
informations jusqu'à la fin du sommet
mercredi ou jeudi
cette rétention d'information confère un
caractère tout à fait solennel à ce
sommet le monde devait assister à
différents à cette rencontre
et puis tout d'un coup plus
d'information on se met
espérer quelque chose doit se passer à
genève où des responsables veulent
marquer ainsi leur volonté dit-on
d'éviter une guerre de propagande
pendant deux jours
cela signifierait qu'il prenne les
sommets avec sérieux comme l'occasion
pour eux de sortir les relations
américano soviétique de l'impasse et il
faut dire qu'on a quelques espoirs ici
puisque des deux côtés américains comme
soviétique
on se dit que tout se passe bien genève
même alan permane soir 3 mais cela dit
le silence sur le contenu des
conversations n'empêche pas certaines
initiatives assez spectaculaires en
particulier du côté soviétique par
exemple monsieur gorbatchev a rencontré
longuement le révérend jesse jackson
l'ancien rival de reggane pour la maison
blanche qui lui a remis une pétition en
faveur du gel nucléaire gilles du
jonchay a rencontré tout à l'heure un
membre de la délégation soviétique qui
lui a expliqué le sens qu'il donnait à
cette rencontre inattendue
il ya eu une cinquantaine de
personnalités américaines qui ont été
reçus par covoiturage et qui ont été
demandé à être reçu par lui dans le
cadre de leur volonté de manifester
cette ce désir de paix que le
désarmement des américains je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait quelques raisons de
faire de sorte que de cette rencontre
soit exclu une personne n'était que la
demande est tout simplement parce que
c'est un quelqu'un qui a été candidat à
la présidence des états unis
que penseriez-vous si le président
reagan recevez un heureux je pense je
crois et je crois que comparer un
dissident quelconque qui est ce prime un
peu foi même ici malheureusement
perturbant quelques manifestations de
presse ses propres vues avec un candidat
à la présidence des états unis c'est
quand même une comparaison hasardeuse
n'est ce pas le gouvernement français at
il signé ou vaty signé un accord pour la
création d'une chaîne de télévision
privée avec le français jérôme seydoux
et l'italien silvio berlusconi
rien d'officiel encore georges fillioud
vient de dire au téléphone à jean-luc
mertens à l'instant que rien n'était
fait et que quand quelque chose serait
acquis sur ce projet ou sur un autre
il en ferait état publiquement rien
d'officiel donc mais la rumeur
s'amplifie en même temps du reste que la
levée de
et contre ce projet après les mises en
garde de la presse écrite et des
industriels du cinéma les politiques
montrent également au créneau
l'opposition dénonce l'offre faite à
partenaires étrangers georges marchais
écrit à françois mitterrand que ce
projet intolérable et à l'intérieur même
du ps du parti socialiste ont dit que
lionel jospin michel rocard jack lang et
pierre mauroy aurait émis des réserves
parmi les craintes le plus souvent
exprimée celle devoir importer à bon
marché des émissions de faible qualité
il est donc intéressant de voir
concrètement ce qui se passe en italie
puisque monsieur berlusconi qui possède
trois chaînes de télévision
hubert coudurier lempire de silvio
berlusconi s'est développée depuis 1976
avec l'abolition du monopole de la rai
son premier réseau canal think we il a
constitué en rachetant plusieurs
stations du nord de l'italie en
difficulté
c'est la chaîne familiale composée pour
l'essentiel de téléfilms américains et
de jeu racheter un groupe d'édition
italia uno s'adresse quant à elle aux
jeunes elle diffuse de nombreux dessins
animés des variétés et encore des jeux
la dernière était quattro est plutôt
destiné aux femmes quelques longs
métrages des novelas brésilienne mais là
aussi à l'exception de tribune politique
point d'information la loi l'interdît au
total des programmes à l'audience
assurer ce qui attire les recettes
publicitaires leur montant dépasse
aujourd'hui la redevance de la rai
à ceux qui lui reprochent d'avoir livré
son pays a des sous produits étrangers
berlusconi rétorque que seulement 25%
des programmes sont achetés hors
d'italie
quoi qu'il en soit son ambition elle est
bien européenne
football 20e soirée du championnat de
france c'était le début ce soir des
matchs retour à tout seigneur tout
honneur commençons par le héros de la
saison le paris saint-germain qui se
déplaçait à lille un match qui s'est
terminée d'une façon bien bizarre daniel
lauclair
le paris saint germain en maillot bleu
et rouge a bien failli perdre le moral
il est pourtant la première mi temps a
été entièrement al'avantage de l'équipe
parisienne beaucoup d'occasions de but à
l'image de rocheteau ici qui a été
contré au dernier moment par un
défenseur ici une superbe reprise de
luis fernandez bien dégagée par jean
pierre mottet et finalement les
parisiens sont récompensés de leurs
efforts sauf coup franc de musique chez
dominique rocheteau qui contre tout le
monde
le gardien et la défense lilloise sur ce
tir croisé 1 0 c'est le score à la mi
temps mais à force de n'avoir pas su
profiter des nombreuses occasions les
parisiens vont finalement se faire
rejoindre but une histoire de famille
pour les lillois pas de stéphane
plancque pour pascal 1 1
on en restera là car à cinq minutes de
la fin de la partie
figurez vous qu'il ya eu une panne de
courant qui a plongé dans l'obscurité le
stade et une partie de la ville et oui
le froid ce soir un jouet des biens bien
ma vie dure aux footballeurs -10 devrait
un froid qui a eu raison d'un générateur
et la partie n'a pas pu reprendre après
45 minutes de jeu comme le stipule le
règlement
monsieur bénalia donc que tu prendre des
mesures énergiques il a donc annulé
purement et simplement la fin de la
partie
et bien sûr c'est une commission
sportive qui va statuer sur ce cas qui
va se réunir jeudi qui décidera si le
match le score est entériné ou si la
partie est à rejouer en tout cas de
cette 20e journée qui était aussi la
première des matches retour il faut
retenir qu'en dépit de la froidure qui a
régné un petit peu partout sur les
stades 25 buts ont été marqués une seule
victoire à l'extérieur celle de lens à
bastia 1 0
il faut aussi noter que bordeaux a
réussi le score fleuve de la soirée 4 à
0 le havre redresse la barre 2 à 0 face
à nancy marseille sans la tête de l'eau
en dominant auxerre 2 à 1
laval renoue avec la victoire chez lui
2-1 face à nice et enfin il faut
souligner le joli score de metz face à
rennes 4 avec trois buts
de jules bocandé a signalé que la
dernière rencontre monaco nantes aura
lieu demain ce qui nous donne au
classement le paris saint germain qui
est toujours leader
quelle que soit l'issue de la rencontre
de ce soir avec 33 points
on suive derrière bordeaux 29 points 3e
nombre qui jouera demain avec 26 points
et dans le bas du classement on retrouve
17e un trio composé de sochaux lille et
bastia 15 points ce dernier lanterne
rouge strasbourg où ça va mal avec
attend ce point de nouvelles démarches
en faveur des otages détenus au liban le
britannique terry wey envoyé par
l'archevêque de canterbury vient
d'arriver à beyrouth pour tenter de
négocier
et puis du côté français après l annonce
faite hier par les ravisseurs que l'un
des otages seraient gravement malade
on pense qu'il s'agit du diplomate
marcel carton on vient de lancer une
nouvelle mission humanitaire et
diplomatique qui doit elle aussi engagé
des pourparlers avec les ravisseurs
joël hasard manifestement le djihad
islamique souhaiterait négocier
rapidement le sort des otages français
son dernier communiqué semble indiquer
qu'ils pourraient relâcher à certaines
conditions
si dans les quatre otages du moins le
malade en fait paris n'a jamais cessé de
négocier secrètement plusieurs
médiations menées au liban en syrie et
même auprès de téhéran
en vain parallèlement des initiatives
privées se sont succédé le doctorat d'un
médecin français d'origine libanaise
avait rapporté l'été dernier du liban
des lettres des deux diplomates fontaine
et cartons ce matin il a repris le
chemin de beyrouth pour la troisième
fois en un mois
mandaté par paris puisque accompagné
d'un représentant du ministère des
relations extérieures
grâce à ses liens familiaux l'avait pu
entrer en contact avec des
intermédiaires des ravisseurs il avait
transmis leurs exigences libération des
auteurs d'attentats contre chapour
bakhtiar remboursement des avoirs
iraniens datant de l'époque du shah
arrêt des livraisons d'armes
l'irak des conditions pratiquement
irrecevable reste que la situation sur
le terrain évolue la pression syrienne
sur les intégristes pourrait se faire
menaçante
il ya donc une petite chance que les
ravisseurs soient tentés de répondre
plus favorablement à une nouvelle
démarche française qui se veut avant
tout humanitaire
le dirigeant palestinien abou abbass
officiellement appliquée par la justice
italienne dans le détournement de la
qu'il est là au rô le parquet de gênes
vient de l'inculper de complicité pour
le détournement du navire et pour le
meurtre du passager américain
en france les chiffres du chômage en
légère amélioration pour le deuxième
mois consécutif en octobre le nombre des
demandeurs d'emploi a baissé de 0 7% en
données corrigées des variations
saisonnières en données brutes on a
franchi le cap des deux millions cinq
cent mille chômeurs alors que peut-on
déduire de ces chiffres et ce qu'ils
peuvent il aurait traduire une tendance
encourageante voûte est effectivement
faut-il s'étonner de la baisse relative
certes des chiffres du chômage depuis
deux mois
oui si l'on se souvient que certains
augures avait prédit en début d'année
que le nombre des demandeurs d'emplois
atteindraient 2 millions 700 mille en
fin d'année non si l'on veut bien se
rappeler que l'arsenal des tucistes est
actuellement fort de 150 mille jeunes
lesquels ne pourrait donc pas à l'anpe
se rappelait aussi que la planète la
panoplie anti chômage du gouvernement
comporte d'autres outils tels que les
stages pour chandler longue durée ou la
formation en alternance
en gros ça représente quelques 200000
personnes ainsi recyclé et de ce point
de vue la politique de l'emploi porte
ses fruits dans la mesure où elle permet
de constater une stabilisation du
chômage la tendance pourrait d'ailleurs
se confirmer dans les prochains mois si
l'activité économique étaient
suffisantes pour ralentir le processus
d'aggravation
certains pensent que c'est possible en
effet alors stabilité oui sur le front
du chômage où personne n'aurait pourtant
l'indécence de se féliciter d'une
situation qui fait état de deux millions
cinq cent mille demandeurs d'emploi en
données brutes
beaucoup de chômage on a reçu
aujourd'hui en ruines
livre donne vos confrères spécialiste
d'économie philippe vasseur son livre à
un titre un peu polémique le chômage
c'est les autres là vous l'avez parcours
alors si aujourd'hui mais le trouvais
intéressant je les trouvais intéressant
parce que c'est un livre qui dit des
choses tout à fait évidente diable
chômage ni de gauche ni droite que c'est
un problème qui ne concerne pas
uniquement les politiques ou les chefs
d'entreprise les uns et les autres sont
tous concernés et qu'il faut peut-être
aborder les problèmes par le par le bon
sens je crois que c'est un excellent
excellent ouvrage comme chez belfond
une autre statistique vient d'être
publiée par le ministère de l'intérieur
celle là elle concerne le nombre des
délits et des crimes constatés il a
diminué de près de 5% au cours des six
premiers mois de cette année
à l'assemblée nationale les députés
continuent de discuter en ce moment en
séance de nuit du bilan des entreprises
nationales le débat ne débouchera pas
sur un vote c'est surtout l'occasion
pour le gouvernement de justifier sa
politique des nationalisations depuis 81
et de combattre aussi les projets
annoncés par l'opposition pour 86 si
elle remporte les élections
fernand tavarès le gouvernement et la
majorité ont pris l'initiative de ce
débat parce qu'il considère qu avant les
législatives les français doivent être
mieux informés de ce qui a été fait
depuis 81 et surtout des intentions de
l'opposition pour l'après mars 86 si
elle revient au pouvoir
la france et ses entreprises ont plutôt
besoin de continuité que de traumatismes
devait déclarer le premier ministre en
ajoutant je ne souhaite pas qu'on brise
leur avenir ensuite montés au créneau
pierre bérégovoy les meilleurs experts
financiers
considère que si aujourd'hui on les met
sur le marché financier
un volume d'actions de 40 ou 60
milliards de francs pour racheter des
entreprises aujourd'hui nationalisées
c'est tout le secteur privé des
entreprises grandes et moyennes qui se
trouveraient privés d'argent je serai
donc une très mauvaise chose pour le
marché boursier mais une très mauvaise
chose aussi pour les entreprises et
l'investissement
au parti socialiste on ne croit plus
beaucoup aux nationalisations alors on
fait des objections technique qu'elle
nous réponde ou très honnêtement quand
on nous dit le marché financier d'après
3 c'est vrai qu'il faut des scènes
dénationaliser très progressivement avec
prudence il faudrait pas non plus que le
désengagement de l'état soit le prétexte
à ouvrir la voie à une sorte
d'affairisme ça nous ne le voulons pas
non plus ce que nous souhaitons c'est
reconstituer un tissu d'actionnaires qui
permettent à ces entreprises de trouver
des financements privés nous opposerons
à tout ceux qui veulent dénationaliser à
la droite mais aussi aux gouvernements
socialistes quand par exemple chez
renault il le vend à l'étranger la
finale électronique renix par conséquent
nous sommes pour la nationalisation et
pour qu'elle serve de vitrine disons aux
choses sociale dans ce pays et au
développement industriel pour une
nouvelle croissance
ce débat sur les nationalisations à 100
mais il ya d'autres déplacements ne sont
intéressants parce que ça permet de
d'approfondir des sujets dont on parle
souvent qui peut superficiellement
on en aura trois autres on va voir après
tout le temps en tout cas n'est pas
désagréable entre l'ogc nice de la
majorité n'ont su positiver pour toi
c'est ton courtois
quant au bilan objectif des entreprises
nationales il est bien sûr difficile à
établir globalement car tout dépend
évidemment des éléments que l'on prend
en considération et c'est ce qui permet
du reste au gouvernement et à
l'opposition de porter des jugements
totalement opposés comme nous le montre
mary kerr tiers côté gouvernemental les
résultats sont jugés globalement bons en
particulier en matière d'investissement
et de commerce extérieur
certes les entreprises nationales loin
d'embauché perdent des emplois mais les
restructurations ont été faites et les
résultat financier s'améliore si on
exclut renault la sidérurgie cdf chimie
et la cgt tous les groupes devraient
revenir à l'équilibré à la fin de cette
année dans le secteur bancaire après un
recul en 1984 un bilan provisoire du
ministère de l'économie présente
aujourd'hui des résultats en hausse pour
le premier semestre 85
côté opposition on réfute ses comptes et
on réclame la restauration d'une
véritable économie de marché
une dénationalisation permettrait alors
d'alléger les charges qui pèsent sur les
finances publiques et de réduire notre
endettement intérieur en faisant rentrer
dans les caisses de l'état plus de 130
milliards de francs reste une question
les entreprises rendu au secteur privé
parviendront-elles tout à trouver des
sources de financement et donc des
acquéreurs du nouveau en ce qui concerne
l'accord sur la cinquième chaîne de
télévision l' agence france presse
annonce à l'instant que cet accord entre
le gouvernement d'une part et d'autre
part le français jérôme seydoux et
l'italien berlusconi que cet accord
vient d'être signé la fp cite une source
se dit autoriser qui désigne
généralement les uns les lieux du
gouvernement la situation sur les
marchés financiers maintenant toujours
excellentes pour les valeurs françaises
à la bourse de paris moins bonne pour le
dollar qui a baissé aujourd'hui henry
lauret dollars a laissé quelques plumes
aujourd'hui puisqu'il a cédé près de 5
centimes à paris la monnaie américaine
fait l'objet d'une certaine défiance sur
les marchés des changes opinion
largement répandue désormais
la bourse de paris fait preuve une
nouvelle fois des meilleures
dispositions les résultats de wall
street hier la baisse du taux de base
bancaire à paris aujourd'hui ont
influencé favorablement
'l'indice des valeurs industrielles le
nouveau record établi par l' indice dow
jones à new york hier soir laisse penser
que wall street est entré dans une phase
de consolidation
le dao ce soir en effet s'est stabilisée
jetons que la plupart des grandes
banques françaises ont baissé leur taux
de base aujourd'hui de 0,25 pour cent
c'est la suite naturelle de la décision
de la banque de france qui la semaine
dernière avait diminué son taux
d'intervention
le temps pour demain de la neige encore
de la neige elle est apparue aujourd'hui
et en abondance si elle tombera dès
demain matin sur tout le pays et en
particulier d'abord sur le quart sud est
dans la soirée elle sera aussi sur le
massif central sur l'île de france et
sur le nord-est
conséquence évidente les températures
resteront froides beaucoup de gelées le
matin et dans la journée le thermomètre
ne montra guère au dessus de zéro sauf
près des côtes atlantiques et c'est
l'autonomie car années de m'asseoir nos
tours avez-vous 19h d'abord avec richard
prix peau pour la première édition et
22h20 pour l'émission de la soirée avant
la suite de la dernière séance je vous
rappelle les principales nouvelles de la
journée
à demain bonsoir
silence autour des entretiens reggane
gorbatchev à genève mais le climat
semble bon légère baisse du chômage en
france au mois d'octobre -0 7% en
données corrigées football lance seul
vainqueur à l'extérieur ce soir le paris
saint germain toujours un à-coup